they were taken away from their families
at the border now some lawyers say the
US government is preying on their
parents desperation to see them again
many of them had been kidnapped raped
tortured but again they said over and
over that that paled in comparison to
the pain and desperation that they felt
being separated from their children as a
result many of them were really
considering signing voluntary departures
and really starting the deportation
process so that they could get out of
detention as soon as possible and they
had been told by ice agents that if they
signed a voluntary departure that ice
would be unite them with their children
as quickly as possible for us we heard
that consistently and over over and over
again to the point that we really feel
that the administration is holding these
children hostage to dissuade people from
pursuing compelling and strong asylum
cases after nationwide outrage over
family separations US president Donald
Trump vowed to public pressure and
announced an end to the policy but his
reversal does nothing for the children
still inside shelters like this one in
Southern California this is one of the
more established shelters for migrant
children here in San Diego and it looks
after boys between the ages of 6 and 17
now it's been doing that for years for
children who arrived in the United
States unaccompanied by a parent but the
difference now is that it is also caring
for children who were intentionally
separated from their parents when they
arrived in the United States as you can
see behind me it is covered in fencing
and green netting all the way around the
perimeter to make sure that nobody can
see out and then nobody can see in the
government agency that contracts this
temporary shelter refused my request to
go inside but they released this footage
showing children's bedrooms a medical
center with painted walls and a place to
play soccer critics say this is the best
case scenario for detained children and
that conditions elsewhere in the country
are likely far worse reuniting them with
their parents will be a slow and
difficult process some children might
even be forced into foster care or
offend by the US government